cette île volcanique fait le bonheur de
milliers de visiteurs chaque année et ce
lundi ils étaient une cinquantaine
nous sommes tout au nord de l'archipel
néo-zélandais white island est une île
inhabitée d'à peine 4 kilomètres carrés
ce touriste américain film le bord du
cratère quelques fumerolles s'échappe et
une demi heure plus tard
lui et quelques autres ont eu la chance
leur bateau les emmène à plusieurs
centaines de mètres des côtes
le volcan a projeté des cendres à plus
de 3500 mètres de hauteur ce québécois
et en croisière sur un paquebot
il voit la fumée au loin un spectacle à
première vue saisissants avant de
comprendre que des passagers du navire
pourrait faire partie des victimes
celle ci était sur ces images prises par
une caméra sur l'île
on peut voir un groupe de touristes
approché du cratère c'était dix minutes
avant l'éruption est la première
ministre
on n'a pas pu être rassurant aucun signe
de vie n'a été décelé plusieurs
hélicoptères ont fait des rotations
juste après l'éruption pour sauver le
plus de blessés possibles
sur l'une des photos prises par le
touriste américain on peut voir un
appareil dont les pales sont tordus
c'est dû à la puissance de l'éruption
nous a confirmé un responsable de
l'entreprise
les cinq occupants ont pu quitter l'île
en bateau
un volcan imprévisible qui a envoyé une
trentaine de personnes à l'hôpital dont
plusieurs sont dans un état grave
ici mathieu prost radio canada